why I wouldn't say necessarily identify
with but respect and admire the way they
think and the way they create the way
they build I mean it goes back to all
the way back to Michelangelo into
Bernini and Stonehenge and from very
primitive things through the change in
the 20th century whether it's some auto
vogner and Adolph loose and Joseph
Hoffman and then Corbusier and and the
futurist I mean it's hard to isolate out
one because all of them play a kind of
tag team in history and the late Louis
Kahn who was struggled so much but I had
the good fortune to actually attend his
lectures was a poet about architecture
and he could distill things down to
their very essence and that's a great
lesson to learn how you can take
something down to what it really means
and its true meaning and find meaning in
that and let all the distractions fall
away because ideas are timeless and when
something is honest it's timeless it's
not an ism those are fashion fashion
movements but the great Luke on and
there's so many wonderful people
calatrava Herod suck and dim where and
zaha Frank Gehry on and on and on that
do beautiful work